my name is Samuel Leeds we're here at
the property investors crash course and
we are ready to learn a ton of stuff so
unless your question guys are you ready
so the only two figures that matter when
you're buying property is one what
you're putting in to what you're getting
thank you I just found a deal which was
giving me a return on investment of how
much 21 percent the 21 percent okay but
it took me how many minutes one or two
minutes to find a deal giving me 21
percent these guys that the property
investors crash bought are about to beat
me and the winner is going to get a
prize raise your hands if you manage to
find a house that was higher than 20
percent
that is incredible give yourselves a
hand very good so this morning we learn
about bottle X and everybody found a
deal amazing now they're finding HMOs
and right now I'm just walking around
reviewing what they're finding and
they're finding some amazing deals it's
just incredible how much you can learn a
nepali in just two days at the crash
course yesterday in day 1 we did deal
saw singers everyone find a deal they
all found a deal so today we're going to
be learning how to buy those bills using
north of arrows Minh and using these
option agreements created finance
ventures and all weird and wonderful
things like that it's gonna be a great
day are you guys ready to learn are you
ready to buy some deals no money down I
hope to see you here next time coming
here being around people that are on the
same mission it's just really refreshing
tonight we'll probably not gonna sleep
making like three six twelve month plus
I am living today with the tools to
actually go up and see if I can get any
deals rent from London and we've
traveled all the way to Manchester I
didn't know what I was gonna get but I
knew that it's gonna it's gonna
basically change our lives the
information the knowledge that he's
given us to go on it just it was just
magical this is worth every last single
second of it and you're only going to
regret it
and not improve your life if you don't
get hit and come do this